And when we graph this, it looks about like
this. It’s a big function that has the highest
value at the center, nineteen and then falls
down in some interesting way that looks awfully
much like the way the previous exercise fell down.
So even for this different experiment with
the die, we get about the same phenomenon that
the sum of those seems to have a distinct high
probability for what’s the most likely outcome
four and then it falls off in some interesting way.
So this is effectively what’s called the central
limit theorem. And this sounds complicated and
in fact it is, but here is the simple version
to remember. Suppose you’re doing many
experiments. Each of these experiments over
here have some distribution, we don’t care,
it has to just be reasonable and you sum those
all up for some very large number and if N is
large then the joint distribution of the sum of
those with approach a function it looks like this.
That’s called a Gaussian. We discuss the
Gaussian in depth. It has its own formula and
typically if N is as big as thirty that is maybe
your test thirty people whether they have
cancer or not, that’s usually good enough to
approximate this really complicated binomial
over here with this relatively simple Gaussian
function. We’ll learn more about this later,
but the key thing to remember is we take many
experiments, you add them up and outcomes a
function just like this. That’s called the
central limit theorem.